so please take your seats we're going to
finish at three so the sooner we start
the soon more CH we'll have to talk
about various questions you may have I
just like to follow
on however with
that
uh film we showed just before we left
for lunch
because
uh it says
something about
Berkshire uh there are you know all
kinds
of public companies and Wealthy public
companies
and uh throughout
America
and there are
certainly
cases where in one
family uh somebody has made a very
large amount of money and is devoting it
to philanthropy or much of it to
philanthropy such as the Walton family
would be the number one thing in in in
in the uh in
Walmart and
certainly Bill did the same thing at
Bill Gates did the same thing at
Microsoft but what is unusual about
Berkshire is that a very significant
number of Brookshire
shareholders located all over the United
States not just
inal but the number of different birgire
holders who
have contributed $100 million or
more to their local charities usually
with
people not knowing about
it uh I think it's many multiples of any
other public company in in the country
it's not not more more MPL than than you
know bills put a whole lot into
philanthropy
and
uh and I don't I don't know the details
of the family but but clearly there's a
huge sum of money that that uh the
Walmart
family uh I'm sure has done all kinds of
things philanthropic and we'll continue
to do it
but I don't think you'll
find any company where a group of
shareholders who aren't related to each
other so many of
them have done something along the lines
of what Ruth
did few weeks
ago just
to exchange a little piece of paper that
they've held
for five decades and they've lived well
themselves they haven't denied their
family
anything uh but they don't feel that
they have to create a dynasty or
anything and they give it back to
society and a great many do it
anonymously they do it in many states to
some extent we see a little some
concentration of it in Nebraska because
uh they
generally uh when you when you're giving
away a lot of money they they call it in
the philanthropic World they call it
absorption capacity and Truth is it's
very it's very hard to give away a
billion dollars to $10 at a time to
people who or needy or something of the
sort and so large institutions have this
absorption capacity which tend to be
universities or colleges or that sort of
thing and some philanthropies are much
more imaginative than others but the one
thing I've
never well most of them want to do it
anonymously so I can't tell there
specific
stories but I have to say one thing that
was astounding is that that the same day
we bought a billion dollars worth of
Berkshire class A stock from Ruth so
that and I guess we we were actually
buying it from the the school at that
point because you just given them the
and then so the transaction was them was
with them but Mark Bard in our office
bought a billion dollar from them but
they also bought $500 million worth
of stock from somebody else that nobody
will ever have heard of and in a
different state and and won't elaborate
beyond that but we have
had a very significant number of people
and there's more to come uh and
obviously they had to be people that
came in early or their parents did or
their grandparents did but they've all
lived good lives they haven't denied
themselves anything I mean that you know
they have second homes and they but
they they
generally uh uh well in fact I would say
the almost
universally they people knew them in the
community everything but they they've uh
they've
used what they accomp what they saved
they denied themselves consumption
themselves that's what savings are is is
consumption
deferred uh and uh they've uh they've
given uh if financed everything all over
the country and usually they like to do
it anonymously I I outed my sister when
I wrote about her in the annual report
but but uh uh Bird's here today and uh
uh I told her she should wear a t-shirt
or something said no solicitors allowed
or something that but the uh but they
just do it
and uh it's really a
uh both Charlie and I felt it's
really uh it's really fun to work for a
group of people like that rather than
for index funds or for for uh hedge
funds or whatever it may be I mean that
the you're just seeing what
people
actually it sort of rest restores your
uh your faith in humanity that people
defer their own consumption within a
family for decades and decades and then
they could do something like and they
will uh I think it may end up being
150 people to pursue different lives and
tal with the people and diverse
people uh to become a dream of being a a
doctor and uh and not have to incur
incredible death to do it or whatever
may be the case there's million
different examples and I want you to
know that uh that
uh you're
very you're
very
uh well you're a unique actually group
of of shareholders among public
companies as far as I know in terms of
the way you've
deferred your own consumption while
living fine
to help other people and and it you know
it takes a lot of years but it can
really amount to something very
substantial and what Ruth did was uh you
know at roughly my age
she looked
at a little piece of paper which
actually was a claim check on the output
of others in the future and she said and
instead of the output
being uh for her that the output would
be for a continuing
stream of
people for decades and decades and
decades to come that we're having a
different life in the pursuit of being
becoming doctors than than they
otherwise would have and and Berkshire
has been
por her husband's Sandy contributed
substantially the
burkers berkshire's
record uh Sandy was a wonderful partner
to have so he it was both input by him
and then there was deferred consumption
by his family and then there was
ultimately this final gift to Albert
Einstein and like I said the same day uh
there was only 500 million it will go to
in a different way but it's happening
all over and I don't think any any
companies like that so I just want to
tell you that it's inspiring to work for
trou
show and Becky go to it all right the
next question comes from slavin VAB brat
um as CEO will Mr Abel be in charge of
the portfolio of Common Stocks that Mr
Buffett has been managing or will this
function be exercised by Mr combms and
Mr wesler as investing could be defined
as the discipline of relative selection
can major Capital allocation decisions
such as large Acquisitions be separated
from the common stock selection
process yeah I would say that decision
actually will be made when I'm not
around and uh I may try and come back
and haunt them if they do it differently
then but I'm not sure the Ouija board
they will get that job done so that job
I I'll never know the answer on whether
I get covered but I feel very
comfortable about the fact that it will
be made
by uh a board that they've got loads of
brain power they got a dedication to a
to an unusual
institution uh and uh they'll they will
figure things out but I would I would
say that if I were on that board
uh and we're making the decision I would
probably knowing
Greg uh I would I I would just leave uh
I would leave the capital allocation to
to Greg and uh uh he
understands
businesses extremely well and if you
understand businesses you understand
understand you understand Common Stocks
I mean if if you really know how
business works you
are uh you are an investment manager
what how much you manage maybe just your
own funds or maybe other people and if
you really are primarily interested in
in getting assets under management which
is where the money is you know you don't
really have to understand that sort of
thing but but that's not the case with
Ted or Todd obviously but I think the
responsibility ought to be
entirely uh with Greg uh the
responsibility with has been with me and
I farmed out some of it and I used to
think differently about how that would
be handled but I I think the
responsibility should be that of the CEO
and whatever that CEO decides may be
helpful in and in effectuating that
responsibility uh you know that that's
that's up to the Amber herds decide at
the time they're running the money but
uh uh so I would say that my thinking on
that has has developed to some extent as
the sums have grown so large at
birchard uh and we do not want to try
and
have uh you know 200 people around that
are managing a billion each it just
doesn't work uh and uh uh I think that
when you're handling the sums that we
will have you've got to think
very strategically about how to do very
big things uh and I think Greg is
capable of doing that I
think I've missed a lot of stuff in the
past uh so I'm actually wiser about
doing that now uh but I
and I uh you know I would do it better
this time around than 2008 and N if
something akin to that happened but uh
it won't be exactly like 2008 or 9 you
can be sure of that but you also can say
that there will be times when uh having
huge sums
available extremely quickly maybe it'll
be once every five years maybe it'll
probably be more like once every 10
years or something but the way as the
world gets more sophisticated
complicated and and
intertwined uh more can go wrong and uh
uh and there's no
sense going through here exploring the
possibilities of the different things
that could happen but you would do do
want to be able to act when it happens
and I think the chief executive should
some be somebody that can weigh buying
businesses buying Stu do doing all kinds
of things that might come up at a time
when nobody else is willing to uh move
it wasn't that people didn't have money
in 2008 it's it's that they were they
were paralyzed and uh and we did have
the advantage of having some capital and
and a willingness
to uh an eagerness even to
act uh and the government that that in
effect looked at as as us as an asset
instead of a liability and I think that
all of those qualities will
be even more
important uh as our capital P girls and
so I think uh Greg may have have even
more fun than I had uh in in a period
when uh extraordinary things were
happening and and we were the logical
place to
go um it uh you never know whether it'll
be next week next year next decade but
you won't be you know mean it won't be a
century from now that is for sure uh and
uh
uh the
more
intertwined and
sophisticated the world financial
situation gets the more vulnerable it
gets in a certain sense it it solves a
lot of small problems but it leaves it
more vulnerable for large
problems Greg does that bother at all or
not with without uh directly answering
the question I think there's one
important thing is I think as we go
through any transition it's important to
know that the capital allocation
principles that Berkshire lives by today
will continue to survive warrant and I
think that's what the thing I'd want to
communicate that we'll we have our
operating businesses Insurance not
Insurance we're going to cap that we'll
provide them the capital necessary to be
successful and grow if it's appropriate
um at the same time expecting a return
of capital from them when they have
excess cash and then as we've discussed
or you've touched on uh always looking
at potentially new businesses as a whole
or in a p and as you've always
highlighted and I fully agree it's a
we're we'll always look at equities as
we're investing in a business either 1%
or 100% but we're looking at the
business we're looking at the economic
prospects of that business and how
sustainable it is and what it will look
like 10 years from now and is our the
capital we originally put in at
exponential risk or or where where's
that risk sit that profile and then of
course um and then we'll obviously have
our our our our continue to always put
excess cash in the safest investment
there is in in US treasuries knowing we
want to maintain that Fortress of a
balance sheet for two reasons one to act
but also to always protect our
shareholders if we have a we want to
maintain the position Berkshire is in
now uh realistically for the to insured
uh to ured
injures well says that it makes me wish
I'd stayed around to be number two
instead of number one in this process
over the years it it's it's uh you know
it it doesn't get more fun than what we
what we're doing and then and uh and
we're better positioned than ever before
we're not positioned though however to
earn extraordinary Returns versus what
American Business generally earns it uh
as I'm you know I would I would hope we
could be slightly better
but nobody's going to be
dramatically better in some in you know
over the next Century it gets very hard
to it gets very hard to predict who the
winner will be and and if you look back
as we did a few meetings ago as the the
top 20 companies in the world that at
10e
intervals uh you realize the game isn't
quite as easy is as it looks but getting
a decent result actually is reasonably
should be reasonably easy if you
just don't get talked out of doing what
has works in the past and don't get
carried away with fads and don't don't
listen to people who have different
interests in in uh mind and the the
interest of our
shareholders okay we'll go to station
number one
hello Mr Buffett my name is Tomo I'm
from dor of
Germany um this is my first time out
here in Omar so thank you for having us
here today so my question is directed to
you Mr Buffett and Mr AEL in 2019 you
reportedly made a bit for the it
distribution business Tech data and
commented that you understand its role
as a
middleman I wonder if you could kindly
elaborate on the
criteria you look at when evaluating it
distribution businesses like T data and
their competitive position thank you
well we had some experience with
distribution businesses and we
know uh their potential to a degree in
their limitations
and uh Greg you were involved that more
than I was so but I mean that was a case
where uh there had been a bid made and
there was a go shop provision right and
uh I think the management probably would
have preferred that we buy it and and
when we went in with a better
bid uh the original party raised their
bid and and we never make the same offer
twice so Greg tell yeah so uh absolutely
in 2019 we saw Tech data as a unique
opportunity when we saw the other bid
and and the underlying value of that
distribution business we did war Warren
and I were talking others made the
conclusion we should talk to management
we talked to the team they were very
interested in uh Berkshire being their
long-term owner uh and we still saw good
value in the in the opportunity and we
had a good understanding of distribution
businesses we have TTI it's not exactly
uh identical DET Tech dat and that
they're very specific to the who their
customers are and who they serve and
supply and who they purchase from
because on a distribution side it's
important to have that input coming in
from from folks who want their product
and you know it's needed on the other
side that there's demand for it and they
had a they had an excellent model uh if
you think of TTI for example that Warren
talked about Paul many times in the
person who founded this business but but
it's a unique business in that uh our
revenues on that business is
approximately $10
billion the average part they sell is a
little over 9 cents 95 billion Parts go
through their
warehouse every every year uh but it's a
model that if you have the right people
on both sides of the equation and you
understand that well there's there's a
unique opportunity there and and that is
something um we saw in in Tech data and
and as Warren highlighted we made our
bid unfortunately it was then taught by
the original bidder and we uh moved on
but we uh we thought very highly of it
yeah we we've probably seen at least
five of them uh in aggregate that over
the last three or four or five years uh
it's not a business that you can dream
about because uh
uh it's a it's a decent business but uh
for example many of the items that the
manufacturer just they don't want to tie
up their Capital you tie up if you have
you know a million plus skus they the
stock keeping unit it's like selling
jelly beans or something like that and
then then and you do you're serving a
purpose to a degree
but you don't you don't really it isn't
your product in in in effect of yeah I
mean you're you're just a good system
for the producer of the equipment to get
it to the to the end user U without
tying up a lot of capital and being in a
business they don't want to be in and so
we we we understand we we we we but
there's no magic to it there was a with
with the PTI you had a
marvelous man running things and and and
he you know and he's and he he
uh
he when you get a marvelous person
running something to some extent that
select for for better people underneath
and Greg and I went to Paul Andrews
Andrews funeral what a few years ago and
there were 300 people or so there and
there wasn't one person that had to say
something particularly nice but
stretched a little bit about about the
deceased I mean everybody Paul Andrews
was The Real McCoy and he was he was an
amazing man and he behaved
wonderfully with burshire I mean he
wanted to do more for burshire than
Burkshire would do for him I mean it was
very s and you run into those people as
I say you run into people to bend over
backwards for us and then some bend over
forwards but that's just the way it is
in this world uh and we've had we've had
quite a few that have been over
backwards for us and uh the distribution
business is not a wonderful business but
it is a business and it's a business
that that if it's big enough it's one we
would look at and we would buy
additional and TTI makes some smaller
Acquisitions on its own all the time I
don't even I don't even hear about them
until I read the quarterly reports and
uh so we we we want to build
up we want to build our businesses in
every area that we operate and we've got
unlimited Capital to do it so so we
we're we're willing to have small
Acquisitions take place if they fit in
with something we already have but we're
not in the business of going out after
small AC positions and if we did we
would we just don't have the people for
it and it wouldn't move the needle
anyway at b or so
uh we
mayor we we would have we would have
been happy doing uh the deal with the
questioner asked about but if we don't
do it it you know it just doesn't make
that much difference we want to do it if
we do it we'll do it well we'll do it
right they'll made the right decision if
they don't
uh you know we will find something else
to do with the
money in the end and and we can always
buy a little more of TTI for you the
shareholders by just buying in our stock
too exactly yeah
okay let's see we need Becky next don't
we yeah Becky all right Warren earlier
you you talked about selling some of the
Apple uh shares in order to build up
your cash Supply and I think it's had a
lot of people wondering what where you
see opportunities or what might be
coming or Market valuation so I'll ask
this question from Foster Taylor at the
1999 annual meeting you mentioned that
if you owned all of America's 500
businesses you would be making $334
billion while paying 10.5 trillion doar
you emphasize that this was not a good
return on investment today by my math
the S&P 500 has a market capitalization
of around 44 trillion with profits of
around .45 trillion this is a very
similar return on investment to the 1999
levels do you see similarities in the
market today and the 1999 levels well
one thing has changed dramatically
from well from
1990 I misunderstood on the 1999 but
uh there have been
times in my life that I've been a wash
in so many opportunities that I
could have invested everything by
Nightfall and then there's other times
when the year goes well not in the early
days but now
uh we we just we haven't seen anything
that makes sense that's that moves the
needle now we've made
small Acquisitions during the year our
companies have made Acquisitions and and
we you know Greg and I may talk about
something that
involves 300 $ million purchase or
something like that and you know it if
if it fits well enough we do it but uh
and if our managers see things that fit
them we want to look at them because our
managers do not have necessarily the
same equations in mind that we do but
there's some managers which we would
have to uh give just say you know
whatever you decide to do and then
there's other managers that wouldn't
that would not know how to allocate
Capital particularly and
that they don't have to be able to be
great Capital allocators if they happen
to be great at serving customers and
understand their own industry and all of
that you know they can be great managers
and a good many of them are capital
allocators and others
are but the
uh this is not this is not a time when
when uh the phone is going to be ringing
often but
there are times from and gr will know
how to handle them as well or better
than than uh I have over time and
Charlie and I would you know we we
missed a lot of things and uh what we
really regretted was missing something
that would not be very big we never we
never worried about missing something we
didn't understand I mean know why why
should we be be able to you know predict
the future of every business anymore
than we can predict you know what what
wheat yelds are like to be in Illinois
next here well not wheat in Illinois
wheat in Kansas but corn Illinois uh so
uh it I I wouldn't I don't really think
of whether it's similar to 1999 because
I'm not that good on chronology anyway
unless something really dramatic
happened at the time I mean I remember
things from 2008 and N better much
better than I remember whether something
happened in 2015 or or 1987 or well 1987
I remember because of October 19th but
but uh uh I'm I'm I just don't think I
don't think that way I just look at what
I can do every
day
GRE um going to have to use nothing
sorry nothing to add okay well we go to
station
to I
mean it's nice to know what lines you
can get an Applause
[Laughter]
for S
two hello my name is Stefan wer I am a
shareholder from Hur Hur Germany
I've been coming to Omaha since
2007 and I'm deeply grateful for all the
things I could learn here both about
investing and about life in particular
creating circumstances that will enable
me to lead a productive life during my
entire healthy lifespan so thank you for
that my
question my question to Warren your
favorite holding period is forever
holding American Express or Coca-Cola
for decades Burkshire recently went in
and out of Marquel and you uh I believe
sold and later bought oxy which I think
happens to everyone all the time um but
can you maybe to us give examples of
your thought process when you exit
positions thank you
well there various reasons for exting
positions one is if you need the money
but that doesn't happen very often with
us but it used to happen on every
decision I made when I started when I
was 20 years old uh which I considered
the post gram period uh uh although I
actually started in 1942 if you just
talk about buying stocks but in any
event uh
the the
uh
decision
process uh is is really quite
interesting in a certain way because
it it we we made Charlie and I made
decisions extremely
fast but in effect after years of
thinking about the parameters that that
that would enable us to make the quick
decision when the when the presented
itself and
uh people have
speculated
on how
I've decided to really put a lot of
money into apple
and for a
reason I can't one one one thing that
Charlie and I both learned a lot about
was consumer behavior that didn't mean
we thought we could run a a furniture
store or anything else but we we did
learn a
lot when we bought a a Furniture chain
in Baltimore and we quickly real
realized that it was a mistake but
having made that mistake made us smarter
about actually thinking through what the
capital allocation process would be and
how people were likely to be behave in
the future with department stores and
all kinds of things that we wouldn't
really focus
St so we learned something about
consumer behavior from that we didn't
learn how to run a department store now
the next one was seiz candy and ciz
candy was also a study of consumer
Behavior we didn't know how to make
candy you know we didn't there were all
kinds of things we didn't know uh but
we've learned more about consumer
Behavior as we go along
and that
sort of background in a very general way
led up to the study of consumer behavior
in terms of apples products and in that
case while I watched what was happening
at the furniture mark in terms of people
leaving the store even though we were
selling Apple price where we weren't
even making any money but it was just so
popular that uh if we didn't have it uh
people left the store and went to Best
Buy or someplace and and if you know the
blumkin they can't stand anybody leaving
the store so you they behave accordingly
but then you
learned you you that had the interest in
the brand and then you had the a million
different
inputs
but I think the psychologist call is
apperceptive mass but there is something
that comes along that takes makes a
whole bunch of observations that youve
made and knowledge you have and then
crystallizes uh your
thinking into action big action in the
case of apple and there actually is
something which which I mean it be
mysterious but I really can't talk about
but it was it was perfectly legal
everything I'm sure you that but it it
just happened to be something that
entered the picture that
uh took all the other
observations and and I guess my mind
reached what they call app perceptive
Mass which I really don't know anything
about but I but I've uh I I know the
phenomenon when I when I when I
experience it and uh uh you know that
is we saw we
saw something that I felt
was well enormously enterprising maybe
I've used this example before but if you
talk to most people if they have an
iPhone and they have a second car the
second car cost them 30 or $35,000 and
they were told that they never could
have the iPhone again or they could
never have the second car again uh uh
they would give up the second car but
the second car cost them 20 times the
Ione did so now people don't think about
their purchases that way but but but I
think about their behavior and uh so we
just decide without knowing I don't know
the faint there may be some little guy
inside the iPhone or something I I have
no idea how it works but I also know
what it I know what it means to people
and I know how they use it and I think I
know enough about consumer Behavior to
know this one of the great products
maybe the greatest product of all time
and the value it offers is incredible
and I think it has
in Tim Tim Cook I think it has somebody
that in in his own way is the equivalent
of a partner partner with Steve Jobs
that could do one thing
extraordinarily
well and and more than one application
but one thing and and and and Tim was
the perfect partner serve sequentially
with them so it it's uh
you sort of know it when you see it I I
actually saw it with Geico when I I went
there in 1950 I didn't know exactly what
I was seeing but lurmer
Davidson on a Saturday in 4
hours taught me enough about what I
understood what auto insurance was and I
knew what a car was and I knew what
people went through people's minds you
know I know I knew they didn't like to
buy it but I knew they couldn't drive
without it so that was pretty
interesting and then but he filled in
all the blanks in my mind as I sat there
on that Saturday afternoon and uh you
know every now and then it happens you
know why do you have this the person you
met you know there are all these all
these different potential spouses in in
the room and then something happens that
you decide that this is the one for you
you know I think was it Rogers and
Hammerstein that Some Enchanted Evening
wrote about that well our idea of an
enchanted evening is to come up with a
business Charlie and me and uh and uh
there is an aspect of of uh knowing a
whole
lot and having a whole lot of
experiences and then seeing something
that turns on the light bulb and U uh
that will continue to happen and I hope
it happens a few times to you but you
can't make it happen tomorrow but you
can prepare yourself for it happening
tomorrow and it will happen sometimes
hey Warren he uh he mentioned oxy which
I think is a great example yeah where
you made the original decision basically
on a a weekend with some thought but as
the more you learned about oxy and the
um the the asset position they had their
their ability to operate in a in in a in
an exceptional Manner and then a a
strong CEO around Capital allocation I
think your confidence in the which was
reflected in continuing to acquire more
shares is sort of that type of process
where yeah it it it's it's exactly to
the point I mean I just learned more as
I went along I learned
enough you know I'd never uh I'd heard
of ocidental petroleum ocidental
petroleum mountains to to uh been a DE
it not a descendant but but it's a
continuation of City service which was
the first stock I bought and of course
uh I I I knew a lot about going on a gas
business but but I didn't know anything
about geology and uh uh so I I knew the
economics of it I I had a lot of various
things stored in my mind about the
business but I never I never heard of
Vicki and
until I guess it was a Friday or
Saturday and we met on Sunday morning
and we made a deal but that was one sort
of deal and then as time passed all the
kinds of different events happened and
you know icon came in I mean there
million things you couldn't predict at
the start and and I formed certain
opinions as I went along but
then uh
a I learned more as I went along and
then at at a point when
I uh heard an investor call that biggy
was
on it it it put things together for me
in a way it didn't mean I knew I had a
sh thing or anything like that I don't
know what the price of oil was going to
be next year but I knew that it was
something to act on so we did and uh
we're very happy we did and we still
don't know what the price of oil is
going to be next year and what he does
but but I think it the odds are very
good that it was and but not a CCH that
it was a good decision and uh you know
we've got options to buy more stock and
and you know when we get through with it
uh we
could it could be a
worthwhile investment for for Berkshire
and and we're in it and we're in it for
Keeps
and uh there are other things that we
own that we aren't in for KS but uh oh
incidentally I I should just throw this
out since there's been speculation on it
we've
sold a I was 100% responsible for the
paramont decision I read speculation
that that one of either Ted or Todd had
some involvement in that no it was 100%
my decision and uh we sold it all and we
lost quite a bit of money and and uh and
that happens in this business too but uh
actually owning
Paramount um made me think even
further uh I like to think deeper but I
certainly uh thought harder even about
about the whole question of what people
do with their Leisure Time and and uh
what the governing principles are of
running an
entertainment business of any sort
whether it's sports or movies or
whatever it might be and uh I think I'm
smarter now than I
was year or two a couple years ago but I
also think I'm poor because I acquired
the knowledge in the manner I did but uh
uh if if I just want to be very clear
that that a we lost money on Perma and B
and I did it all by myself
folks I don't know whether I've
anticipated one of Becky's questions now
but we we will uh we will find out let's
see now you yeah you're next Becky y uh
yes you did anticipate one of the
questions um let's go to another one
this um this question comes from Vincent
James in Munich Germany in the
Chairman's letter Warren points out that
the profit margins for BNSF have slipped
relative to all five other railroads
however Warren comments in the letter
BNSF carries more freight and spends
more on Capital expenditures than any of
the other five major railroads and has a
vast service territory Second To None
given the comments from Warren about the
clear strengths of BNSF what explains
the decline in revenue and profit and in
particular the profit margins relative
to the other five railroads what are the
ISS issues relative to the other
railroads and what is being done to
address them please be specific okay and
I will well how specific we get depends
on what
uh Greg wants to say but Greg
is that it's Greg's responsibility it my
responsibility for the purchase and for
the operation up till Greg to took over
but I think I'll let Greg answer that
then sure yeah the the the uh Warren
touched on it and the comments from the
uh as reflected there are are very
accurate if you look at uh this
quarter's results or
our uh last year's results um they were
both uh they're disappointing as
shareholders and disappointing in the uh
Rel relative to the other class one
railroads and as highlighted in the
question there's five other class one
railroads so it's pretty easy to um
um understand how you're performing
versus the others and it and there's a
lot of other variables but there's some
very um simple things to look at when we
look at where we've been on uh uh with
associated with Burlington I would I
would just back up a little bit um
because if you go back
to uh 2021 the Burlington team and
management team and the group we're
making excellent progress on a lot of
fronts when it comes to are uh operating
and both being efficient and effective
in how we're operating the railroad and
I remember very specific comments from
myself in 2022 where I commented that uh
that was a year there was all the supply
chain issues a lot going on in the west
coast ports our trains were backed up in
a variety of
places and we called that a reset year
and I think we did need a reset year on
the operational side but as we moved
into
um
23 the business cost level cost
structure we didn't reset it to the
underlying demand we were
seeing uh we anticipated more demand and
the or and we did not reset our cost
structure and the team's working very
hard as we speak to to um both reset the
cost structure and allocate the cost
resources uh where they need to be
uh and and when you go through something
like that uh what we've recognized as an
organization yes the the demand of the
rail will will drive a certain amount of
the cost but the the reality is that the
rail industry if you go back many many
years it's it's it's flat there's not a
lot of growth in the industry there's
opportunities to become more efficient
effective and our margins can go up but
the reality is the demand's going to be
flat but it does move move within
different sectors of the rail it can be
in the consumer products it can be an
industrial it can be an egg but overall
it's generally going to be relatively
flat so we need to get our cost
structure right and we need to get it
right both for the the coming year but
for the long term and that means it's
going to be a continuous exercise We
Can't Stop we can't say we we've gotten
far enough because our competitors and
we compete with the other rails but we
also do compete with the truck industry
we have to have a cost structure allows
us to compete both within our rail
industry and within the transportation
sector as a whole so the team at
Burlington's working very hard to
address the cost structure uh just like
we have in the past I think one thing uh
we do recognize when the other railroads
have implemented uh Precision scheduled
railroading there's other metrics that
we have to continue to pay attention to
and and challenge ourselves if we're not
at their level what are the things that
are driving it so we're going to when
they ask for specifics I'll give you a
few uh we have to look at our Rail Yards
and understand how we're how we're
managing that we have to look at our
locomotive Fleet both the size and how
we're utilizing that and challenge
ourselves and we have to then go back to
how we're using our employee resources
and allocating them across the the
business so there's a lot to be done
there our team's 100% committed to uh uh
driving to the right cost structure
that's consistent with the underlying
demand in the business and uh and then
we can't stop there is the is the answer
so a lot to be done but we have a a team
that's uh absolutely engaged and
committed to it and we'll make uh we're
going to uh make good progress in the in
in this current year at burshire we want
everybody to have the idea that there's
a lot to be done with every business you
know it so I mean it
is uh you
we F PE he would build a remark
remarkable company in om Building
Company really remarkable and there
question after everything they did that
something that was
done particularly well you know digging
a tunnel under the East River or
something when it said it couldn't be
done he would say he would be he was
pleased but not satisfied and that is
exactly the way we want the attitude to
be at Berkshire forever uh Omaha is a
railroad town if if President Lincoln in
1862 I think it was had decided to pick
St Joe or plmouth or any place else to
build the Transcontinental Railroad all
would probably be a little T of 20,000
or something on the banks of Missouri
but but making
with Lincoln's desire to make this the
uh Eastern Eastern Connection uh make a
Transcontinental Railroad all all just
took off so it's
been it's been R it's been
railroading at its
base the uh you know and anybody that
was interested in financial matters had
to think about railroads uh was they had
a certain climber or to them anyway but
the interesting thing is that up which
is our main
competitor uh themselves fell way behind
20 or 25 years ago before Jim before Jim
young came in and in 200 whenever it was
eight or so I started buying three
railroad stocks and north and uh it was
Union Pacific BNSF and and uh Norfolk U
Western I believe I don't know why I
wasn't buying CNO but in any
event
uh Jim young had done a marvelous job
with being with Union Pacific uh so we
we were owned all three stocks but what
we did in
2009 is we were
able well we already own 22% of it but
overall it was $35 million
a billion dollars which was a
significant part of our Capital we were
able to put it to work in a in a
business we
liked and we there's certain tax
advantages that come in terms of making
money in something
that's more than 80% own but call it
100% owned in this case versus making it
through stocks so it has a a net benefit
to us from making the same amount of
money owning one of the other railroads
by owning all of the railroads and we
got 35 billion
out during a recessionary period I think
that was the worst quarter the third
quarter of 2009 maybe the the rails that
had for a long time so it's it's worked
out actually it's worked out very well
but it's because we we were putting out
capital in 2008 and n and if we put put
money in anything we'd have made a lot
of money but it's more satisfying and
it's actually better in certain ways
tax-wise to make it from something
that's 100% owned and a all B bunch of
uh you know 5% or 10% owned
uh uh businesses we're you know as I
mentioned in the annual
report railroads are absolutely
essential to the country that doesn't
mean they're on The Cutting Edge of
everything they're just essential to the
country and uh you know it it uh that's
why the government you know I think they
took them over one time and they they
negotiate what our labor settlements
will be and everything and and if you
shut down the railroads of the country
you you it be would be incredible the
effects uh but and it would be
impossible to construct now I mean it
look at what's happening in California
when they're trying to build a line I
mean you know everybody's worried about
the environmental effect of of every
Mile and you know and what'll happen to
the various species of birds can you
imagine the rail system of the United
States being built it it it would it
would take decades unless a war was on
and the government took over things and
just ordered them
you can't create it so we love owning uh
a business like that it's going to be
around 100 years from now won't be the
best growth business in the world at all
during that period but it'll be
essential and and what it earns in its
relation to its pit it's it's its
replacement value is a pittance but
we'll do fine in terms of what we paid
for it and we'll we'll distribute
substantial amounts in relation to what
we paid
uh to Berkshire in a very tax efficient
way and uh so
it's it's uh when when the question is
what are the issues rela to the other
railroads uh you know it wouldn't have
been the end of the world if at all if
we bought the Union Pacific and Jim
young had stayed alive to run it for us
that would have been great too but but
we had the opportunity to to buy BNSF
and it's been good for the and it's been
good for us and we think it's been it's
a very important asset to the country
and you know I just hope we can find
something in other industries that where
it makes as much sense as that where we
can put a whole bunch of money to to
work uh at an advantageous
time uh so let's go on
to station
three is that correct or not yeah yeah
yeah
okay K good afternoon Mr bu Mr Able my
name is s po wo a resident of New
Zealand but originally from Thailand
this is my first time in America and the
first time attending the meeting the
journey was quite rough but it was all
worth it though because I can now
personally thank you Mr Buffett and the
late Charlie manga where he still with
us for organizing such a wonderful event
and most importantly for being such an
exceptional role models and sharing your
wisdom with us all these years so thank
you well thank you for
coming so here's my question for you m m
Mr Buffett towards the end of 2018 you
mentioned that you guarantee you could
make a 50% annual return if you had to
start again with under $1 million the
question is
if tomorrow you woke up in the body of a
of of bodyy old americ P body but that's
fine and your name was now Warren
alakat and you have some money to invest
on a full-time basis what method or
method would you use to achieve that
return would it involve flipping through
20,000 pages of Moody's manual or
similar publication
or finding you know to find sticks or
would it be hunting for great companies
at a fair price as Mr mle wood or would
it be a combination of both with
opportunity cost serving as the final
Arbiter of which method to use given
that your investing opportunity has now
broaden significantly thank you K good
question I'm glad you came and the uh
the answer would be in my particular
case it would be going to the 20,000
pages and since we were talking about
railroads you know I went through the
Moody's Transportation manual a couple
of times that was 1500 or 2,000 Pages or
well probably 1500 pages and I found all
kinds of interesting things when I was
50 or when I
was uh 20 or 21 and I don't imagine here
there's anybody here that knows about
the Green Bay and Western railroad
company but uh there were hundreds and
hundreds of railroad companies and I
like to read about every one of them the
green band
Western uh in those days everybody had a
nickname for for railroads I mean that
was that was just what Northern Pacific
was the Nipper and you know Phoebe Snow
was one of them in the East that used to
go up to Cornell and uh the green band
Western was known as grab baggage and
walk ah and
gbnw and they had an they had a bond
that was actually the common stock and
they had a common stock that was
actually a bond and you know that that
could lead to unusual things but they
wouldn't lead unusual things that would
work for you with many millions of
dollars but but if you collected a whole
bunch of
those which I set out to do and actually
that's what impressed Charlie when I
first met him because I knew all the
details of all these little companies on
the west coast that he thought I would
never have heard of but but I knew about
the Los Angeles Athletic Club or
whatever it might be and he thought he
was the only one that knew about that
and that that that uh that became an
instant point of connection so to answer
your question uh I would I would I I
don't know what the equivalent of
Moody's manuals or anything would be now
but I would I would try and know
everything about everything small and I
would find something and with a million
dollars you could earn 50% a year but
you have to be in love with the
subject uh you can't just be in love
with the money you really got to just
find it like a you know essentially like
you know people find other things in
other fields cuz they just love looking
for a biologist looks for something
something because they they want to find
something they and it's built in I don't
know how the human brain works that much
and I don't think anybody not
understands too well how the human brain
works but but there's different people
that that uh just find it
exciting to expand their knowledge in a
given area we
uh you know I know great bridge players
I know great chess players actually uh
kaspar came to all and met Mrs B I've
had the luck of of meeting a lot of
people that are unbelievably Smart in
their own Arena and do some unbelievably
dumb things in other areas so all I know
is the human brain is complicated and
but it does its best when you find out
what your brain is really suited for and
then you just uh pound the hell out from
that point and that's what I would be
doing if I if I had a small amount of
money and I wanted to make 50% a year
but I also wanted to just play the game
and you can't do it if you really if you
don't find the the game of Interest
whether it's Bridge or whether you know
whatever it may be chess or this case
finding Securities that are undervalued
but it sounds to me like you're on the
right track I mean anybody will come all
the way to this annual meeting has got
something in their mind other than
Bridge or chess uh so I'm glad you came
and come again next
year and now we
move Now we move to Becky uh this
question comes from Denny Poland a
shareholder from
Pittsburgh when describing the principal
agent problem Mr Munger said that
capitalism often works best when the
people managing the property also own
the property in recent years agents of
Pension funds and asset management firms
who do not have significant personal
ownership stakes in birkshire have
forwarded proposals that were not in the
economic interest of shareholders what
can be done to limit the negative
influence of these agents in the decades
after you're no longer able to cast
significant votes against them well
that's that's a very perceptive question
and and it's been answered in a
temporary manner but but but who knows
what these other the situation will
develop in the future all I know is that
you have a wonderful hand that Burk sure
out the way but you have to you have to
be able to think your way I mean
obviously you have to think your way
through political realities and you have
to think your way for what will cause
you want a you want to be on you you you
want to be regarded as an asset to the
country because uh you'll find more
solutions if you are
are uh an asset you ow to the country
anyway but but beond that you'll you'll
find more solutions and if if you're
regarded is evil or or something and
worse yet if you deserve it so it it
it's it's it's something that's
constantly in our
mind uh and it needs to be in the mind
of the directors and they need to think
for themselves on this rather than about
uh conventional wisdom uh uh
which uh you
know in in a sense you don't want to
become ayic about life but almost
everybody that approaches you if you
have tons of resources is has got some
interest in figuring out how to use your
resources to their advantage and and
that's true whether they're in politics
or whether they're in Investment Banking
or whether they're selling you uh uh
well whatever it may be that they're
selling I don't want to do any injury to
anybody but but uh you know life
insurance agents see the advantage of
buying life insurance and and investment
managers get paid based on assets manag
to get interested in selling you their
services imagine if everybody in this
room were following the investment
advice of somebody that said you know
for 1% a year I'll tell you how to
invest your money and in 1950 when we
started in
19 65 they would have they would have
said well by burshire halfway and and if
they were around now and they still had
their 1% deal they'd be
collecting 8 billion a year from people
who aren't getting any dividends from us
so yeah they they would have a different
interest in in the kind of contract they
worked out with you than you would have
and best thing to do was just pay him a
commission one time and on the stock but
you have to be alert to
how what human nature does to both other
people and to you and uh uh then you uh
uh you know if you think of if you think
it through well and actually
listen to uh what Charlie has told
you
uh you'll have a big head start on most
people Charlie there's one thing that I
should mention that really is terribly
interesting about Charlie Charlie knew
the
importance of
psychology and human behavior and
incentives and all of that he he figured
that out very early and of course he he
gave some talks even on you know 25 or
so ways whatever it happened to be I
don't remember the exact number but
different ways that one person could
take advantage of another by
understanding how humans
behave and then after doing a
magnificent job of explaining it he
believed in understanding what others
would but he thought it was beneath
him and to actually use those methods to
manipulate
people it's a really interesting human
being
that thinks through the psychology of
human behavior and figures
out you know how you become a great
insur
Insurance uh salesman or manager on Wall
Street or accumulat assets under
management or whatever it may be and you
get very rich by understanding the
weaknesses of others to some extent and
then decide that it's very important for
you to recognize these when they occur
it's very important for you to know them
better than the person that actually is
using them but not but you don't have to
stoop to using them yourself and and
Charlie told me that that uh you know
his in his lifetime after he figured
this out there were a couple of times
when he used them he wasn't proud of it
but he also never lied to me so uh he uh
he uh explained to me that you know
there there were a couple times when he
used some of these techniques but but he
it wasn't he didn't plan on using him
anymore but but he also wanted me to
know that if if if I ever did something
like that I wasn't really behaving
terribly that he he allowed for he
allowed for the fact that humans humans
May misbehave so I'm sure that uh I
behaved somewhat better before my
marriage and I did afterwards in my
enthusiasm for different activities like
dancing or something and and and he said
that's you know we all do it but don't
do it again
so let U that's part of acquiring human
wisdom and speaking of human wisdom
we've just got that one book out there
by Charlie um I mean poor Charlie's
Almanac and that's worth reading three
or four times I think I read Ben
Graham's book about five or six times
and each time I read
it I realized that I I just needed to
think a little more deeply about certain
things they weren't complicated or
but
uh you know it it's better to if if
you've got some great instruction like
you get with Charlie it's better to read
it several times than to just figure
you'll just read every book once and
it's in the
library okay let's go to section
four uh Jeff robier from Tulsa Oklahoma
and I'm thinking of Dr Graham Mr M
your father and my question is for all
of us but it's probably especially for
the younger people in the
room uh the importance of picking the
right heroes in life choosing friends
wisely and maybe tell us a story if you
could about each of those folks thank
you sir well there's no question you're
100% right in terms of of uh having the
right Heroes and and
uh you know you're you're lucky if you
get them I mean Charlie had Charlie had
him I had him and the interesting thing
my sister is here
today uh my younger sister that uh with
the two
survivors uh
and we both
experienced
having the same hero even though
As We Grew Older we saw that we didn't
agree
with plenty of his ideas but we did
agree with his values and
motivation and that's that's a better
lesson than having somebody that reading
to you from a catechism that is has got
a lot of rules in it which are pretty
good rules but but there's a
special special place for somebody that
that is going to continue loving you
even if you break some of the rules and
uh that's what Charlie had in his life
was what Bernie and I had in our life so
so I would I would just repeat what you
said I'm don't need to give you a bunch
of well I when I um ran away from home
I'll give you a specific example with me
I when I ran away from home and went we
had shed up to Hershey Pennsylvania and
got picked up by the state police and
everything and I talked these other two
guys into it and uh we lied like crazy
to the state police you know saying we
had our parents' permission some some
some kid at the uh place where we stayed
had kept them off that we'd run away
from home and we started like I said
when the state police picked us up we
decided that two things you know we de
decided to tell them bunch of lies about
the fact we had our parents' permission
and we decided we better get out of pery
because these cops were going to find
out soon or later and uh so anyway we
end up back in Washington after a couple
days and uh when I walked in the door
uh uh well one of the boys mother and
this other kid was a congressman Roger
Bell and his mother was in the hospital
over this whole thing he'd taken out his
cash in the savings bonds and so she was
sick and judge Bell her husband was all
concerned and everything and I walked in
the door and in Washington and my mother
said how come you came back so soon and
my father
said he he said I I know you can do
better and
uh and uh I just paid more attention to
my father my mother and uh so you want
to have the right Heroes and and you
don't have to have them it's not the
heroes based on what they've
accomplished and it's it's you know it's
it's it's uh it's it's the people that
you want to be yourself and uh if you if
you copy the right people you're off to
a great start and I don't
mean great start about making money I
mean a great start about living your
life so you can check with my sister
birie use here and see if I've told the
story correctly she ran away from home
too incidentally but but uh she didn't
get as far as I got but uh uh she was
running away to go over to my
grandfather's house which was about two
miles
away uh but I don't want to denigrate
her runaway abilities because she she
was much more accomplished than than I
am and all kinds of other things but
when it comes to running away I I
definitely uh out CL
true okay let's go to Becky this
question comes from vant Sharma in India
Warren you and Charlie have often said
that you were able to identify the
people you want to go into business with
and have had an exceptional record in
that however in the case of pilot we
noticed that the final stake purchase
ended up in a dispute and had a sense of
smart accounting to put it one way to
squeeze a little more out from the deal
than was deserved by the seller knowing
well that this has been settled out of
court and needs due confidentiality I
would like your views on some of the
lessons learned that may be beneficial
for future deals to watch for and for
coming leadership to look out for as
well well I I'll I'll make two comments
on that that a couple of the directors
had our doubts about their doubts about
going in uh and uh in any event pilot is
working out well for us and as my friend
Sam Butler one time said to me that and
he was talking in general about certain
kinds of situations but he said well
Warren he said all is well that ends and
that's where we
[Laughter]
are so we'll go to station five
well while we're getting to station 5
I'll tell you a little bit more about
the fellow that is now running pilot I
knew you may have met here that uh Greg
known for a long long time and he grew
up in
Omaha and uh uh came from a poor family
and was raised by his mother right
and went to the same high school public
high school that my wife went to North
High went to University of Maha set an
alltime record in in in the rushing
yardage at playing there he was a
bouncer yes drafted by the New York
Giants as I remember exactly yeah and uh
uh but
then injured actually in spring training
I as I remember in some way and so
he ended up being an
intern not an intern but a trainee you
might say for for mid- American before I
was there and uh and now he here he
is uh still relatively young and he's
running a
huge company and we we've
got incredible confidence in what he
will do and we like very very very much
the business that was created by by Big
Jim hlam and uh uh
the you know it it really is almost an
only in an American type story but it it
does show
you with somebody with some real stuff
and with a mother of that believes in
them and with bad breaks along the way I
mean imagine how you'd feel if you were
drafted by the New York Giants and and
then you suffered some injury in spring
training or something I mean you know
you spend your it just it hurts but uh
it's not an experience I would have ever
had it's I me that was the last guy
chosen but the uh uh you know to see
that he's running a company well depends
on the price of the deal but a huge
company and uh what does he have 20
25,000 yeah employees yeah and and he's
got many many many years to go so I
couldn't be more pleased about not only
the acquisition of pilot but but just
what it it tells you about America you
can C what what do you have to look up
read about him in Google or interview
with ad yeah um try to think of it's a
podcast yeah he he's he's got a podcast
that will just blow you away and if you
don't think this is a a great
country and has a lot of great people in
it all I got to do is read that podcast
so but we do have a great set of assets
here oh yeah you know if you look at
Pilot we have 800 more than 800 station
Travel Centers and just so everybody
knows I mean the beauty of that and
there is a question regarding this
morning around fuel choices at Pilot and
the exciting thing is in the end is
going to serve whatever fuel our
customers need it can be electric it can
be renewable diesel it can be diesel um
or any of the various sustainable fuels
but the point is it has exceptional
locations that are on the interstate
highways and we hundreds of them
hundreds of them and we bought an
incredible franchise and now we have a
great leadership team in both Adam and
his team that's around him so we're
we're we're pleased where that
opportunity will go go yeah we've
got probably the average one might be 10
or 12 acres or something like that Zone
commercial on interstates throughout the
whole United States I mean it it who
knows but uh but what was created there
is amazing too yeah follow the the
played at University of Pennsylvania I
mean University of Tennessee uh and uh
undefeated and uh uh came away from this
football team and you think well another
football player you know maybe the he
goes out and and there may be some
intermediate Parts in the story a little
bit but he he buys a gas station and he
turns it into something that is huge so
it's we're we're really delighted with
with it and uh
and You Know It uh it's another kind of
only in American story and
uh uh you know how many of us can become
an
All-American number one rank team let
alone start a a business that that goes
on these sort of heights so we feel very
good about it Becky no I think they're
ready for five now oh I I think he's up
there now he's ready to go okay go to it
um hello Mr Buffet uh my name is j y I
came from uh micro City hyan China so I
want to express my sincere gratitude for
you for the extraordinary value you
generated for
shareholders and the positive influences
you've had on younger generation of
investors like
us and uh my question relates to the
concept of maximizing the duration of
compounding as individuals age the
quality of compounding inevitably
diminishes what are your secrets in
maintaining your sharp man extraordinary
judgment and great physical condition we
wish you well thank you well it don't
know me well but that's I
like just keep talking I
mean the uh well I you know you have to
be just point lucky I mean there's no
question about it that uh that uh
there's 100 or a thousand you know
multiply a number of times that some
drunk could have pulled out of the car
and broadsided me or you know just all
the bad luck that you can have in life
and I you know you can say that my my
great skill has been avoiding bad luck
but that isn't a skill that's luck or
bad bad bad the and and you know and
then to get to be you know I would not
have been a if You' taken my high school
class and you say you know a couple of
you are going to live to be 90 men are
going to live to be
93 I I got you know I wouldn't I would
not have been a heavy favorite I can
tell you that and I wouldn't have bet on
myself uh but uh you
just now you you should make the most of
your luck when you get it and sometimes
I've done that and sometimes I haven't
uh I mean it is absolutely true that if
I had to do over again there there'd be
a lot of different choices I would make
whether they would have ended up working
out as well as as things have worked out
it's hard to imagine how they could have
worked out any better so so I but it is
interesting how many mistakes you can
make uh if you just keep going and
Charlie you know when you to talk about
that that you just Soldier through you
just keep going and but you still need
luck you don't you don't want to anybody
that says I did it all myself is just
kidding I mean it's just it's uh they're
delusional and uh uh you know actually
live in a country where the life
expectancy is pretty darn good you know
so that alone is a huge plus I was was
born if I've been born my sister's here
and she was born female and she's just
as smart as I was and everything but but
even my own family who
really did well particularly my dad Lov
us all
equally uh and and and in a terrific
manner but he still told me that that
this is 10 or well I was born 10 years
after the the 19th amendment was pass
and but he told basically told my my
sisters you know that Mary young well
you still have your looks and he told me
that the world you know that power and
new is new in
nature and that uh you really could do
anything well I found there were a lot
of things I couldn't do but but uh it it
the message given to females and
males was incredibly
uh different by the most well-meaning
and loving of parents you know like I
say in 1930 I mean it been that way for
millions of years it's it's
changed quite
dramatically but obviously not com
completely but during my lifetime but
it's been during the latter half of my
lifetime if you take my sisters if
they'd been born even five or 10 years
later they would they still would have
been
uh you know getting instructions when
they went away to college to be sure and
be sure and get married while or get
ranged so that you're going to be
married you know while you're in school
because after you get out all the all
the good ones are taken that was birdie
was telling me that was a message that
that you know basically was had been
imparted uh to most of a lot of the
women she had met obviously and so
it it
really it's it's extraordinary how much
progress we made but it's it's
unbelievable how long it took to get it
made I mean it uh it really does make
you wonder about you know we've got all
these heroes from American history and
all the wonderful things they did but
but how could they say all men are
creative equal and then write a
constitution that women you know allowed
women not to be able to own property and
depending on the state I mean just
terrible
conditions but anyway that's how you
learn about what the humans can
[Applause]
do and I feel and you got to feel better
about the future for your kids than you
would have felt 100 years ago no matter
you know what the situation is
anyway we'll move to
Becky this question comes from Linda
Frasier in Westport Connecticut Dear Mr
Buffett in the past you've specified
that 90% of your wife's inheritance be
invested in a lowcost S&P 500 Index Fund
and 10% in short-term government bonds
but the market cap of The Magnificent
Seven tech stocks now represents more
than one quarter of the market cap
weighted S&P 500 Index which seems like
a big bet on the tech sector I was
wondering if you would now recommend
investing some portion of the funds in a
lowcost equal weight S&P 500 Index Fund
rather than having all of the equities
exposure and a tech heavy market cap
weighted fund well that's an interesting
question and and I will tell you that I
I revise my will about every three years
or so and I get little thoughts from
time to time and then you don't you
don't change it every time you do it uh
you get a tiny thing but uh uh uh the
one section I haven't changed is that
that with my wife that she she get
left a huge amount of money by prly
anybody's uh measurement
except pittens Compared to What U I've
accumulated in total and it doesn't it
won't make one bit of difference to her
in life uh whether she beats the S&P or
anything else Al all all I want to leave
is plenty of money to take care of Way
Beyond anything she'll ever spend and at
the same time give her as much peace of
mind as possible and and really make it
so that the trusty who administers it
doesn't really have to doesn't have to
worry about whether it just doesn't make
any difference whether she beats the S&P
or not and the main thing is that she
feels that she feels that she's in a
financial position which of course she
will be that uh she doesn't even need to
think about it and the trustee doesn't
have to worry about getting sued or
anything else so it's it's it's
uh it's simply not an economic condition
now obviously with 99% plus of what I
have going to to uh philanthropy and and
you know and I've got my three children
and the one good thing is that
they at the age of 70 69 and 65 they
have matured remarkably probably more
than their father and uh that uh but the
at the same time they've got less time
to work with the money than they would
if you know they were 50 or something
like that
so you do you do the best
in in accomplishing your
objectives in your
will
and and in the end uh you know you can't
you don't know what's going to happen
after you die but you make sure that
that uh to the extent that you
leave you have a lot of money to leave
you take obviously you uh you want to
say thanks to a lot of people in quite a
few people in terms of specific requests
you want to take care of the your family
but but in my case that requires
practically no money and and the uh a
fair amount for taxes but I have and my
children are in charge of what happens
to the funds that are left but like I
say the the problem is when you live as
long as I have and kids get older you
who knows what happens with mortality
tables and they're the ones that I
really uh want to see them handle the
distributions and they will and they'll
be very good about it and uh
uh but if we're all alive 3 years from
now they'll be three years older and so
everything you can't solve everything in
life you do the best you can with it and
uh uh people do interesting things I've
been around probably as many rich people
as almost anybody and a fair number I
know what they're they're doing or have
done with their funds and uh the idea
that you can
have a huge amount of
money and leave everybody very rich and
have
people liking each other less when it
all happens is it's humans are really uh
they are interesting to watch some of
them handle it beautifully and others
are terrible one thing lawyers always
tell you is
um don't don't use ctools in other words
you know when you change your mind on a
will just write a new one but tear up
the old one don't do it by just adding
carols uh but I believe I'm
correct uh certainly read it that Paul
Getty who was the richest man of the
world
presumably uh at one point in the 1950s
or 60s and it's very interesting guy to
read about and he had five W five
U uh wives and he's the one whose
grandson was kidna kidnapped and they
they sent sent bti
a an ear of the child and everything I
mean it it's not it's not a happy life
when you get through it but the one one
thing he he did that was kind of
interesting he actually lik to use
cardols because I think he had like 25
of them and it was kind of his way way
of writing well I'm taking you out of
the world because you know and so he he
he uh he he sort of delighted in
explaining through his will what uh uh
how he felt about all these people I
mean you really get some
strange things revealed well I just I
just read
about uh a will of fellow that made a
whole lot of money was leaving it to his
uh I don't know whether his children
grandchildren whatever it may have been
but in any of it his opening line and
his will is is and this was done some
years ago but I know something about the
family uh his opening line in effect
said I'm writing this will while I'm
writing in the economy session of
Eastern Airlines number such and such I
mean he believed in getting getting
right to the point of what what what the
people who were recipients how they
should live and he was going to be
judging them and it's just so damn
interesting to watch people's Wills but
uh you know one one guy left a lot of
money to his uh wife on the condition
that she Remar so that at least one man
would mourn his passing you know
what well I'm not giving legal advice
here as they always say but
but I feel I feel very very very good
but how things have turned out and uh uh
and I wish I could figure out ways
better to use you know the really vast
resources I've got in the some of the
really important questions of the world
but
but I haven't been able to do that I
mean I had a few goals when I
was 30 or 40 in May of britam and the
wills then in terms of what the world
needed done and how the money could
be used and unfortunately I decided that
it just they weren't feasible to
accomplish them and of course I was
setting out to accomplish things that
that were important but nobody saw yet
so you got to expect that why why should
I be able to solve them but nevertheless
it it's a it's an interesting but and
the one thing about it is everybody here
I don't know about the ones who' have
come from other countries but they
should you should have a will because if
you don't have a will you still have a
will and it'll be whatever the state say
and it's amazing four American
presidents died in tested without Wills
four you know we've only had four 45 and
imagine becoming president of the United
States and not having a
will uh
but you can look up a somebody reason I
think I think
Lincoln uh I'm certain Lincoln was one
of the four and here's a man I
mean I don't know what you can always
say well he didn't get around to it but
that but that's hard to imagine that
that uh why Abraham Lincoln would have
died intestin I'm sure we've got some
Lincoln Scholars out there that will
write me after this and explain why but
I and I'll be interested to receive
their
letters but human beings are human
beings and and uh we all have weaknesses
and peculiarities and everything else
and don't be too hard on yourself
uh because you have some of those but
don't be totally forgiving either you
can change the future you can't change
the past but you can't change the future
okay station
six um good afternoon my name is
Caroline and I'm a lawyer in San Diego
but please don't hold that against
me remember Mr Munger was once an
attorney too right
um first I'd like to sincerely thank you
Mr Buffett for your business Integrity
tireless leadership and generous
contribution to
philanthropy my question for the
distinguished panel of two is now that
the AI Genie is out of the bottle as
someone astutely put it earlier today
what business in Berkshire hathway may
be most at risk with
AI well that's a wonderful
question uh
the problem is I we don't know anything
about AI but
uh uh
obviously you know anything
that's labor intensitive intensive and
that uh that
uh it can create an enormous amount of
leisure time now what the world does
with leisure time is another question uh
whether more Leisure Time
I know an awful lot of people think when
they go to work at first that what they
want is leisure time and what I like is
actually having more more problems to
solve
and uh but AI is
profound I mean that's what makes
it makes it a genie you know is what
what going to happen
uh uh
oh uh I could tell a few Genie jokes but
better or
not uh but uh I guess wer we probably I
don't know what you
know in terms of our businesses they'll
figure things out I mean we've got smart
people
and it's obviously if it's used in a
pro-social way it's got terrific
benefits to society
but I don't know how you make sure that
that's what happens anymore than I know
how to be sure that when you use two two
atomic bombs in World War II that you
knew that you hadn't created something
that could destroy the world later on
yeah yeah I think when we think of AI at
a lot of the business units I mean we're
truly weren't trying to think uh how
does it make us more efficient more
effective I mean it it results in more
idle time and we're probably not
thinking of the iter iterative I AI
where um we're looking at very specific
processes where people can implement it
and either at times it displaces the
labor but then hopefully there's other
opportunities for them within the within
the business but I
think you know when you think of all our
businesses I mean we're we're we do have
a heavy labor workforce in a lotum but I
think we at the stage we're at as a as a
company and and maybe where it's at
right now it's really around how do we
do things more effective more
efficiently um more safely if it's
involves dangerous processes so it's
we're we're early
Innings yeah John John mayard KES was
just wonderful to read and incredible
mind but in in around the time I was
born he uh he wrote a book about what
could happen uh I don't whether it was
in the next 100 years or whatever and
and he predicted correctly that that
that output per capita would grow at
this incredible rate that it has but uh
in terms of speculating is what people
would do with that I mean this this guy
was unbelievably
smart and but uh it hasn't developed
exactly the way he predicted he was
right
about what was going to go into the
equation but he wasn't he didn't have
figured out exactly what at all what
what what uh would be the result so it
it
is it is
really well we didn't know when we were
developing the bomb that there would
probably
be
that's very soon nine countries free of
whom we should worry about plenty that
we'll have what they have but we didn't
really have any choice and you could
have had all kinds of Papers written on
and everything else but we were going to
do it anyway we needed to do it and if
you haven't read it it's fascinating to
go to Google and read the letter by Leo
zard and Albert Einstein to President
Roosevelt written about a month before U
almost exactly a month before the uh
Germany or Hitler moved into
Poland
and it laid out well Li's
Lord knew what was going to happen but
had a good hunch of what was going to
happen in terms of nuclear bomb
development and he he couldn't get
through to Roosevelt but Roosevelt but
he knew that that a letter signed by
Albert Einstein would so it's probably
the most important letter ever written
and you can read which it's just
fascinating to me uh
but that started the manatt project that
started you know it just everything
flowed out of it and like I I'll bet
anything that Roosevelt didn't
understand it but he understood that
Albert Einstein just sent a letter and
and uh and he probably knew what he was
talking about and and he better get he
better start the Manhattan Project it is
it is it's just unbelievable what
happens in this world anyway let's move
on to uh Becky I guess is next right yep
um Randy Jeffs from Irvine California
the March 25th 2024 Wall Street Journal
reported that the treasury market is
about sixfold larger than before the
2008 2009 crisis do you think that at
some point in time the World Market will
no longer be able to absorb all of the
US debt being
offered well I would say the the of
course I don't know but the but the my
best
speculation uh is that
us that will
be acceptable but uh for a very long
time because there's not much
alternative but it won't be the quantity
it it you know any any you know the
national that was nothing to speak of
like you know for a long long time and
then uh
uh it won't be the quantity it'll it'll
be
whether in any
way
uh
inflation would get but
Loose in a way that that really
threatened the whole world economic
situation and there really isn't any
alternative to the dollar as a reserve
currency and you get a lot of people
will give you a lot of speeches on that
but that that really is the answer that
and uh and Paul vulker worried about
that back in 19 you know well before
1980 but but he had threats on his life
and I happened to have a little contact
with him at that time and
uh he was an amazing
amazing fellow that uh that in effect
decided that he had to act
or
the really the the financial system
would fall apart in some way that he
couldn't predict and and uh and he did
it and he you know had people threaten
his life and do all kinds of things and
but he was the man for that
crisis uh
but it it wasn't the quantity of US debt
that was being offered that threatened
the system then it was it was the fact
that that inflation and the future value
of the dollar you know the cash is trash
type thinking the
turn you know that
that was setting up something that could
really affect uh uh future of the world
in terms of its economic system and Paul
Booker took it on and uh he was got his
could be and if you haven't read a book
or two about them uh or the one he last
roote You' be able to take a look at it
uh but
uh it is I I don't worry about the
quantity I wor about the fiscal deficit
you know if it it but I'm not a worrier
just general I mean I I think about it
and uh uh but uh I don't sit and get up
work myself into a stew about it in the
least but I but I can't help thinking
about it and
that's uh we've got a we've got a great
attention it's it's interesting I think
media enters into this and uh focusing
the focuses on the fed and they you know
they just love it because things are
always happening and economists are
always saying what's going to happen
with the fed and everything else but uh
uh the the fiscal deficit is what should
be focused on and uh
and uh J poell is
a a a not only a great human being but
he's he's a very very wise man but he
doesn't control fiscal policy and every
now and then he he sends out a kind of a
disguised plea for please please pay
attention to this because that's where
the trouble will be if if we have
it
yeah as one of the comics used to say
there's a standup coming used to say who
have I forgotten to offend after just
talk and I always feel like that after
these meetings but we've got we've got
time for at least one question and maybe
two but let's go to station
7 hello my name is Dennis from gon
Germany I'm my first time here I'm here
with my friend who would by the way love
to invite you to dinner you talked about
the importance of Heroes and we are very
happy to and thankful that we have you
as our hero with great values and uh
thank you for that first of
all my question is it is clear that you
achieved great success in life earlier
you talked about every investment having
opportunity cost from what I've learned
in life that does not only apply to
investing your money but also to
investing your time and every hour you
spend in your office is an hour you
cannot spend with your spouse or
children with the life experience you
have now if you had the possibility to
start all over again would you set your
priorities any any different if yes how
and why and what's the best way to
invite you to dinner
well well that definitely won't be one
of my priorities if I figure
out but that isn't don't take it
personally because that uh when when you
know you can figure out the at the
maximum how how long a period I've got
and
uh don't I don't think uh I mean I can
figure out all kinds of things that
should have been done differently but so
what you know I mean I'm not perfect I I
I don't believe in lots
of self-criticism or being
unrealistic about either what you are or
what you've accomplished or what you'd
like to do you do the you know you do a
lot of things and and uh who knows
whether somewhat different
tradeoffs
uh
um you know you just can't you can't you
don't know where the past would have L I
feel I I don't think there's any any any
room in beating up yourself over what's
happened in the past you know it's
happened and you and you get to live the
rest of the life and you don't know how
long it's going to be and and uh you
keep trying trying to do the things that
are important to you and and if I was a
a doctor or if I was a you know all
kinds of different professions I might
do different things but I really
enjoy um managing money for people who
trust me I don't have any reason to do
it for financial reasons uh you know I'm
not running a hedge fund or getting an
over right on anything but I just like
the feeling of being trusted Charlie
feel felt the same way you know that's
that's a good way to feel in life and uh
uh and it continues to be a good good
feeling so I'm not really looking to
change much uh and uh uh you know if I'm
very lucky I get to play it out for six
or seven years it could end tomorrow but
that's that's true of everybody although
the equation isn't exactly the same
but I I don't believe in beating
yourself up over anything you've done in
the past and I don't
believe
in well I believe in I believe in
trying
to find you know what what you're good
at what you
enjoy and uh and then I think the one
thing that you can inspire to be and
because this can be done by anybody and
it's amazing doesn't have anything to do
with money but you can be kind you know
that's you can be kind if you're uh and
the the world's better
off yeah I'm not I'm not sure that the
world will be better off if I'm
richer but there's no question that I
mean and you know kind people and in the
end
uh aspire to be
more or I'm sure many of you are
yourself but just aspire to be more so
and I guess we can take one more
question from Becky and then we've wind
up uh this question comes from Devon
Spurgeon on March 4th Charlie's will was
filed with the County of Los Angeles the
first kotto kodil contained an unusual
provision it reads averaged out my long
life has been a favored one made better
by Duty imposed by family tradition
requiring righteousness and service
therefore I follow an old practice that
I wish was more common now inserting an
ethical bequest that gives priority not
to property but to transmission of Duty
if you were to make an ethical bequest
to Berkshire shareholders what duties
would you impose and
why I'd probably say readed Charlie and
I mean he's expressed it well and uh I
would well I would say that that if
they're not financially well
off uh if you're being kind you're doing
something that most of the rich people
don't don't do when they even when they
give away money but uh uh that's not a
question of when you're whether you're
rich or poor and uh and I would uh I
would say if you're lucky in life make
sure bunch of other people are lucky too
[Applause]
okay there's just in case you know what
my advice to myself would be has been
during this
[Laughter]
period so we only got 30 what three
questions or whatever this but thank you
very very much for coming and I not only
hope that you come next year but I hope
I come next
[Laughter]
year thank
you thank you
[Applause]